من اهم المبررات التي ساقتها موسكو لشن
حربها على اوكرانيا زحف الناتو شرقا في
اتجاه الحدود الروسيه لكن هذه الحرب دفعت
فنلندا والسويد لطلب عضويه الحلف فماذا
تعني هذه العضويه تعني اقتراب الحلف اكثر
فعمليا سيضيف النيتو
متر من الحدود مع روسيا وستمكنه الحدود
الفنلنديه من اطول حدود بريه معها وهذا ما
سيعزز وجود النيتو في منطقه بالغه
الحساسيه وهي بحر البلقي في عام 2004
انضمت دول البلطيقه الثلاث ليتوانيا
للحلف لكن صغر حجمها والبعد عن مركز الثقل
في الحلف جعلت تلك الدول تعيش خوفا دائما
من جارها الروسي الان بانضمام فنلندا وفي
انتظار انضمام السويد سيتعزز امن هذه
الدول الصغيره منطقه اخرى لا تخفى اهميه
الاستراتيجيه هي القطب الشمالي الوضع
الجغرافيلندا والسويد سيمنح الحلف نفوذا
اوسع في المنطقه الشاسعه بعد اكمال
انضمامهما ما يشكل تهديدا للمصالح
الاستراتيجيه لروسيا التي استثمرت كثيرا
هناك بعد ان اظهرت الدراسات غنى المنطقه
بالثروات الطبيعيه تعد مملكه السويد من
الدول القليله في شمال اوروبا التي تعاملت
بجديه مع روسيا القيصريه طوال قرون وخاضت
معها حوبا لبسط النفود هناك ولذلك فعندما
يكتمل انضمامها الى الحلف ستجد روسيا
نفسها امام تحدي لا يستهان به وما يزيد من
حجم هذا التحدي ان السويد تعد قوه عسكريه
كبيره وتملك صناعه حربيه من بين الافضل في
العالم فهي تصنع غواصات وصواريخ وطائرات
متطوره وتملك سلاحا جويا يعد من الافضل في
اوروبا والعالم كما تملك قوه بحريه لا
يستهان بها اما الجيش السويدي فهو جيش
محترف يعتمد على التقنيات الحديثه ويملك
عتادا متطورا وانضمامه الى الحب سيقويه
ويزيده فعاليه في الشمال الاوروبي ورغم ان
قوه فنلندا العسكريه اقل من السويد فان
وضعها الجغرافي ربما يجعل انضمامها اكثر
ازعاجا لرو سيا فرسيا التي سعت لابعاد
النيتو تجده الان يجاورها على امتداد مئات
الكيلومترات وقبل الانضمام بسنوات قامت
فنلندا بعمليه تحديث لجيشها وخصصت ميزانيه
كبيره للدفاع